switch gears and talk about another kind
of food dog nuts a legendary spot in los
angeles now here in las vegas talking
about randy's donuts opens this morning
on the west side of town part of the
grand opening you're going to want to
listen here carefully they are giving
away a free glazed donut to every
customer
starting at 6 a.m so you've got like 15
minutes to get out the door go get your
donut mary jane bellies is there now
mary jane how many donuts have you eaten
well i do want to say john and heather
i'm saving eating the donut part for
after when i get out of here because i
know once i eat one i'm not going to be
able to stop i mean there's just so many
donuts to choose from obviously the
glaze is their well-known iconic flavor
here and it's been pretty busy it's been
pretty packed so far we have a lot of
the lines kind of starting to form
outside but i am joined bright and early
with ashley collegian she's also part
owner of this business and ashley thank
you so much for joining us i know that
you have woken up so early you and the
workers have been pretty much
making everything in the last couple of
hours so tell me about that yeah we're
so excited to be in las vegas it's
obviously our first store out of state
and our head baker we've been here
since 10 yesterday i got here around 2
a.m we're just pumping through excited
to serve the vegas community well we're
excited too and i mean everything smells
amazing how many donuts do you think you
guys are gonna be dishing out i mean not
just this morning but maybe throughout
the whole day oh the whole day thousands
maybe even close to ten thousand we just
want to be able to serve the community
and make sure everyone gets a taste of
uh la landmark oh absolutely and i know
that there's a line already starting to
form out there so i'll let you get back
to work ashley thank you so much we
appreciate it and again you can get a
free donut starting at 6 00 am and there
will be a grand opening ceremony a
ribbon cutting happening later at 11 a.m
as well so come on down and get your
donut reporting live from saharan
rainbow mary jane bellissa live local
now wait